euromaxx highlights and here's your host
guy in hempstead greetings from berlin
and a warm welcome to our highlights
edition but shapes up this time with
lots of great summer fun including this
water Wonderland we check out europe's
wildest water slides status symbol
exploring the relationship between women
and their handbags
openair optra the arena di verona
celebrates a landmark anniversary
but with the repeated heat waves that
have hit Europe this past summer what
better way to cool off and to go for a
dip well thats odd has had many people
heading to water parks all over the
continent many of which are boasting
elaborate water slides that give you
literally real rollercoaster thrills and
so we asked a couple of experts to take
the plunge and check out some of the
wildest rides
a 32 metre plunge at more than 100
kilometers an hour
you
you stand there and you know what's
going to happen it looks really exciting
and I really wanted say if you feel I go
don't be I don't [ __ ] I'm scared so
much I lied not on my own only if
someone goes with me it's too high for
me
last year the carnival world waterpark
in Italy opened the tallest slide in
Europe we met up with German brothers
you Leon and Luca chesh both of them
experts superfecta or chili mousse the
perfect slide has to be tall and fast
you have to really feel the adrenaline
and it has to be well built smooth
sliding and comfortable it's most fun
when you're really squeezed in going
around the curve boss the brothers run a
website dedicated to giant slides in
their free time they travel all across
Europe testing water parks they've tried
out more than 600 in the last four years
many captured on video and put on
YouTube
but they've never been on a slide as
tall as this despite the intimidating
height Yoo Lian rises to the challenge
it's obvious you can't think about it
too much so I'm going to take the slide
now just before the trap door opens he
turns on the camera and Geronimo
let's have on it's fantastic the start
alone you really just drop then you're a
top speed until the end you just go
incredibly fast I'm going to go down
again right away what's that say like
not my higher steeper stranger they're
serious competition among amusement
parks for extreme water slides here one
even goes straight through a shark tank
the kilimanjaro slide in Brazil is
almost 50 meters high the tallest in the
world mammoth in the u.s. is the longest
covering almost five hundred and fifty
four meters slides that go to the limit
but are still safe that's the challenge
for their designers every slide created
by ina bone in his office in Stuttgart
means coming up with new ideas and
solutions
stones z4z call me to imagine you're
coming at the water at 100 kilometers an
hour at that speed the surface of water
is as hard as concrete people so I have
to come up with special techniques to
make the water softer like injecting air
into it we win the media's fossil by
shovel China pounds most spectacular
slide was the world's first double
looper in virga Austria and uilleann
chesh and his brother Luca came to test
it muscle slides are getting extreme in
recent years we've seen entirely new
developments and I expect some very
interesting projects in the next few
years a view of the Alps and then 14
meters of freefall that provides the
speed to complete the two loops
it was hydrated excellent it's really
fun and I'd recommend it to anyone to
get their adrenaline levels back to
normal Yoo Lian and Luca then go on a
column a ride wiser and still in their
element
well if you're in Britain and wish that
you had more time to enjoy works of art
or at least to learn more about them
well then your wish has very likely been
granted that's because all over the
country replicas of the nation's most
famous works of art are currently on
about 20,000 posters and billboards with
corresponding phone apps that tell the
whole story well it's an amazing
collection chosen by the people for the
people and what better way to learn
about Britain's greatest artists it's
not often you see a Damien Hirst on the
side of a brick building or a war scene
overlooking traffic an installation by
Amish cop or in front of an apartment
block art everywhere is bringing
Britain's greatest works of armed to the
streets all over the country for two
weeks
I think it's amazing to have access to
art in the underground and on the
streets on the Billboard so I think it's
really incredible actually I think it's
a good idea because it gives people who
don't go to art galleries the
opportunity just to wander across art if
four people don't have time to go to
museum they can see it on the street
it's more better than advertised it's
accessible is free and the public can
enjoy it whenever and however for
example when shopping on your way to
work or waiting for a bus we're all
accustomed to optical stimulation but
usually from the world of advertising
now you can see works of art instead
like john singer sargent's gassed sir
john everett millais painting Ophelia is
on show and Hackney
and a bus trip to Westminster Abbey also
includes free art
all over Britain the country's greatest
artists like Lucien Freud are being
shown on more than 20,000 posters and
billboards the entrepreneur Richard Reid
came up with the idea for this open-air
gallery I used to walk to work every day
down a fairly rough Street in London but
on it some would have put up this
beautiful picture and it wasn't there
for any other reason then it was just
this thing of great beauty and we were
talking about this and how it gave me a
bit of a lift when I walked into work
every morning and we just thought I
wouldn't it be amazing if you did that
absolutely everywhere the works of art
for this unique nationwide exhibition
were not selected by art critics the
public voted online for British
masterpieces of the last six centuries
57 of them were selected crowd funding
with a minimum contribution of less than
5 euros paid for the prince and the
advertising industry donated the
billboard space for free for two weeks
it's not the real art but it's a
stepping stone and these are like big
advertisements for museums big
advertisements for art as a concept in
in people's lives and I would be amazed
if these posters don't send people into
museums they will
sir peter blake a pioneering figure of
british pop art hopes that art
everywhere will stimulate interest in
painting I prefer the people went and
saw the painting but perhaps they will
perhaps a pass it here and find out
where it is and go and see it so so it's
not as good as looking at the original
but it's okay you know but it's it's in
addition to that Blake designed the
famous cover for the Beatles sergeant
Pepper's album that too has been
reproduced a phone app reveals which
museums the original works of art are
actually displayed in art lovers all
over Britain are now looking for the
pictures photo galleries have been put
online with pictures from Glasgow
Norwich Manchester and elsewhere posted
on Facebook and Twitter I have to
confess I did walk up here earlier on
didn't see it I've seen a few on the
underground around like one around by
the tube and another one while you're
walking through the station but I
haven't seen many more than that
the pictures aren't always conspicuous
outside the museum they sometimes get
lost in all the other visual
distractions of the city but the
organizers hope to do this again it is
relatively cheap to do it but it takes a
lot of goodwill and a lot of effort to
do it so I what I'll be interested a if
we do it next year and be if it takes
off elsewhere in the world and I've a
sneaky suspicion that it will art
everywhere has made Britain the world's
biggest open-air gallery with another
week still to go well speaking of works
of art some women's purses are actually
good enough to be in a museum and in
fact in Munich in southern Germany and
exhibition on the history of handbags
has just had to be extended due to the
huge crowds coming in well most women
put great consideration not to mention
money into purchasing a handbag and
whatever their sizes purses do function
as much more than just a carry-all and
so we went to see why handbags are such
incredible objects of desire and why
we're very seldom satisfied with just
one they can be edgy they can be elegant
big or small American or British named
after celebrities or even made by them
versus and handbags are a favorite of
fashionistas so desirable they're not
even a price tag of several thousand
euros would be a deterrent Olivia
hambrook least um could we have regular
customers some of them even stick to
just one label believe it or not they
come in every other month or so to buy
the latest bag from their favorite label
or they buy a second or even third bag
they particularly love in another color
we see a lot of that a call from Yoda
this everyday 180,000 people visit the
luxury Cal faustos festoons department
store in Berlin one of the most popular
departments is called the loft a
treasure trove of purses shoes and
accessories that opened
last year to cater to the growing demand
so what is it about handbags that makes
shoppers hearts race is for Natasha I
guess one factor is that purses like
shoes have nothing to do with your
figure you can buy whatever you like
without having to worry about the size
understand for our Suzuki invites and
under the closest the media is also
fueling the trend every season fashion
Bibles like vogue promote the new it
bags a term coined in the 90s for a
designer handbag that becomes a
must-have among the first eight bags for
fendi's baguette and the Louisville Tom
speedy both available in limited
editions bus for like Naruto while a man
might splash out on a watch a woman is
more likely to splash out on a handbag
it's a treat a handbag is an investment
one that its owner can really show off
with let's see Mitzi home Blake was it
sighs they're often warned very
ostentatiously so that everyone sees
them their status symbols bus oh he
doesn't convert this is a hard artisan
for the bavarian national museum in
munich is currently hosting an
exhibition about the history of the
handbag called touchin these elaborately
embroidered 16th century purses were
among the first bags worn as accessories
rather than hidden inside the folds of
clothes
documenting over 500 years of handbags
the show is packing in the crowds and
has already been extended interestingly
it shows that handbags have never been
predominantly functional across the
centuries they've always been a personal
statement the touch point of a handbag
was to have a place to store personal
items when you're out and about that's
why it's always been a very
individualistic accessory as anything
Keegan's tunnel also on display in
Munich are some of the world's
best-known handbags Chanel unveiled its
255 in 1955 and it remains a best-seller
equally iconic is the Kelly bag launched
by French luxury brand MS and named
after actress Grace Kelly it costs at
least 5,000 euros and anyone who wants
one has to add their name to a waiting
list and that's apparently not just an
advertising gimmick the Skip initial
Fiedler's there aren't many people who
know how to make these bags the other
factor is the material though he the
more exclusive and exotic the leather
the less of it is available this will be
nuts why you have to wait a while if you
order a crocodile Kelly bag this man
iron a coke or kelly beck I'll sleep on
cam a handbag speaks volumes about its
owner's taste and style but why is the
men's handbag never really got on the
thigh point as the point when they
started getting fancy like the ones you
see here and became fashion accessories
for women was the point when men stopped
wearing them before that they'd worn
very elaborate hunting bags but they'd
fallen out of fashion by the 19th
century that later they had briefcases
our wallets they kept in their pocket
but in the course of the 19th century
banks became very much a woman's
accessory 19yo not voted d Tasha dunzo
I'm a little vibration access one
and a pricey purse isn't necessarily
just an indulgence some designer
handbags could be a real investment as
long as they're properly looked after
elizab are cliche or part truism when
you attribute certain characteristics
and quirks to a nation whatever it is
expats to Germany certainly do find some
unusual idiosyncrasies here one of them
is adam fletcher of Britain who now
lives in the German capital and he has
turned his observations into a book that
covers a pretty broad range of everyday
subjects ranging from tilting windows to
crossing the street in Germany many
people have preconceptions about what
Germans are like they enjoy beer they're
proud of their country and they ride
their bikes a lot but how much truth is
behind the cliches what is typically
German all those old cliches like
punctuality everything works orderliness
so our code you know which kind
attention to detail precision slice hard
work that's typically German for me and
organic food britain adam fletcher is a
keen observer of the germans he moved to
berlin in 2010 and has written a hand
book called how to be German in 50 easy
steps it all started with the blog in
which Fletcher wrote about typical
German habits the 30 year old has now
turned his observations into a book
hi my name is adam fletcher and i'm a
germany enthusiast and cultural absorber
and today you're going to learn what I
think makes you really German all
holders of beverages must complete the
sort of awkward drinking dance in which
everyone must make very very obvious eye
contact with everyone else in turn an
old glasses must touch all other glasses
beer gardens wouldn't be the same
without bratwurst a staple of German
cuisine but people here consume less
meat than many other Europeans 89.2
kilos per capita per year putting
Germans in ninth place Germans are
nearer the top of the list when it comes
to potato consumption however and the
country is also known for its huge
variety of bread
this is a very important area of German
life yeah this is a Michigan trinka I
feel like this is one area with Germans
really like to run wild anything goes
when it comes to Mishka trinka and that
they almost feel sorry if there's just
one liquid that's alone in a glass that
there may be that liquid is it in fact
Longley they should put another liquid
with it so can have a kind of glass
party Fletcher is not the first
foreigner to wax lyrical about life in
Germany of course books filled with
quips observations and complaints from
outsiders have often proved quite
successful in Germany itself the Germans
are interested in knowing about their
own culture from the perspective of a
foreigner the offensive Kip is a very
very good example that since the book
came out everybody talks to me about
fence staff Kip and they can't believe
that only Germany has capable windows
like the Germans can't accept but this
is a German think that all windows must
be like this but they're not a German
windows I find the Germans behavior the
the road ample mentioned is very funny
so the her example one time I crossed
before it was green and just someone
shouted and how had me and I was like I
crossed on the red man I'm sorry there
was another time where there was a
mother with her daughter we really got
into a conversation about my behavior
and how I was setting a bad example for
a child and I tried to say well look all
I'm doing is really teaching your child
how to cross the road you know about the
help of a light bulb separating crash is
another typically German thing Fletcher
thinks it's a funny obsession since no
one knows whether all the carefully
separated items won't end up in the same
place again
I'm really a big fan of Germany and I'm
really happy living here you know and I
call myself an honorary German and yes
you should feel proud to be German and I
hope that my book helps in some way to
to lighten people on the good parts of
German culture now to be able to teach
Germans more about their own culture
Fletcher is brushing up on his own
german language skills and we'll finish
off with one of the most popular opera
festivals in the world held in one of
the most famous Roman amphitheaters the
arena in Verona Italy is itself nearly
2,000 years old but for exactly one
century now it's been reopened as a
modern performance venue and it still
remains true to its past which is why it
celebrated that anniversary with the
same song it opened with back in August
of 1913 this is the same production of
giuseppe verdi's opera Aida that was
staged here exactly 100 years ago I eat
in 1913 is the name of the project and
it's one of the highlights of this
year's centenary of the arena di verona
more than 30,000 visitors attended the
special evening performance
you
it's incredible awesome especially
because it's acoustic unplugged there's
an incredible mood incredible acoustics
it's so authentic it's amazing it's
lovely I like atmosphere and feeling
even from this distance you see it's
done the with heart okay Lucas yeah I
think it's important to offer the
audience and historic Aida so that they
can really understand the history of
Aida Pisco mint a la storia di either
the arenas archive has been carefully
maintained over the past century a
stroke of luck for this production
because it contains documents from the
original 1913 Aida
it was one of the world's first mammoth
opera productions it's absolutely
fantastic because of the of the of the
dimension of the space and which offers
a lot of opportunities to the directors
and gives a lot of opportunities to put
on stage many people for the triumph
it's in our we are talking about 300 350
people on stage
the Roman amphitheatre built nearly
2,000 years ago hosted games and shows
in antiquity
thousands flocked here when it reopened
in 1913 one of the initiators of the
classical music stage was the tenor
Giovanni San otello he devised a simple
test to see if the acoustics were
suitable for opera the test was with two
musicians to clap the hands and to see
how the result of the acoustic are very
simple but always the simplest things
are the the most clever things in life
usually many operas have been staged
here over the past century most of them
works by Puccini and verdi italy's most
popular composers with over 600
performances aida is the favorite a year
ago the arena opened a museum two
exhibitions marking the centenary of the
Opera House show the great singers who
performed in the venue Maria Callas had
her debut here Luciano Pavarotti called
it his favorite opera stage he used to
say that when a singer can perform in
arena it's ready and he's arrived as in
a career point of view playing the part
of Aida is Italian soprano fiorenza
chitterlings a world-class opera star
she garner spontaneous applause as she
heads to dinner after the performance
this is my fourteen seasons in a--in
arena di verona it is it was my great
honor my great pleasure my joy really to
be here to sing in Aida the best roller
in the in the in the in the Opera maybe
this historical era in the arena di
verona is being performed until
mid-september
well don't forget to check out our
Facebook page just in case you'd like to
see any of those reports again and with
that we have reached the end of this
edition of our euromaxx highlights so
until we meet again from all of us here
in Berlin Alice kuta choose won't off
you dezzy
you